i mean like how did you get into it i
think that i've read something about
anxiety and things like that but you
know what was the impetus to send you
down this path of being able to just you
know just throw content at us like crazy
and it just clearly flows out of you
yeah i um i mean my background's in
nutrition and so it's always just been
more focused on food like the food
aspect and the biochemistry of the body
and i
growing up have had so much issues so
many issues with bloating where it was
so severe where i after every meal i
would eat i would have to lay down on
something because it would just be so
painful that i couldn't like sit up
without feeling like i'd like unbutton
my pants or something because it was
just so expanded and i especially during
that time i feel like there's a lot of
stuff going on on social media where
it's like bloating is normal like look
i'm really bloated too and i remember
that can't be the case like the body
can't just all the time you eat be like
okay now we're gonna make you incapable
of doing anything now
um so then it this is a while ago my
dad's chiropractor and he um was
learning about fasting and
i was very scared of that concept i was
like i can't possibly go without food
like no way
when i wake up i eat every two hours
like that's what i've always been
trained to do especially in nutrition
space
uh but then eventually the bloating just
got so bad where i was like okay
and maybe there might be something that
could help with this and it was just so
miraculous on how
well it cleaned my gut how well it just
completely eliminated bloating i never
get bloated now unless i'm doing
something wrong that i know i shouldn't
be and
it makes it that i never want to go back
and i want other people to feel that way
too
yeah i i that you like totally hit it
right on the head for me it's like
people would describe me as being
disciplined and i don't really
go off too much and to me it i don't
have a desire to be like a big old cheat
day where i eat a bunch of pizza and
gluten and dairy and all kinds of stuff
that i know will make me distended or
feel bad because like my main goal is to
feel good and so i can feel good trust
me i can eat plenty of calories like i
have no problem consuming calories or
eating all day long if i need to have a
you know if i need to jolt my metabolism
because i've been you know sort of
repressing it for a while with any kind
of restricted eating um
which i don't normally do so i stay
pretty regimented but it's totally the
feeling good and what's crazy is that
people i think there's a like there's a
lot of people that don't even know what
feel good
means
yeah and i mean my whole like slogan
with my channel is that i want you to
feel good again but also a lot of people
don't even have that again part it's
like for the first time and that's
actually been something really cool to
see with clients or just people who are
commenting on my channel where they're
like oh my gosh i didn't realize that i
didn't have to feel this way all the
time or i didn't realize how badly i was
feeling a hundred percent of the time
until i started to actually feel good
what is the most common thing that
people um cut out that makes a big
difference
you mean in terms of like food or
fasting yeah yeah food i'd say food
off the bat
yeah um
snacking
i mean it's not it's not even a specific
food it's snacking because that's why
intermittent fasting is so great for
especially the gut healing aspect which
is what you're going to feel the most
immediately you're going to feel less
bloated you're going to not get gas and
like that distension and that's
something you feel right away and with
snacking you are breaking up the same
benefit that you would get from fasting
where you're stopping the gut cleaning
process called the migrating motor
complex if you've listened to like any
of my videos you've probably heard me
say it 20 times that like it's all the
big words i love it
it helps educate people i mean that's
how i learn i love to i love to hear
things i haven't heard before so feel
free to go as deeper as and in
specific as you like
yeah um and with when you remove
snacking you actually activate that even
between meals so it takes three and a
half three hours 45 minutes like pretty
much that specific area-ish of number to
get a full cycle of the migrating motor
complex to be completed so if you were
eating like every two hours you're never
actually cleaning out your gut which
means you're always getting that
bacteria and left buying food built up
in your small intestine and so any other
food that's coming through is just
getting fermented and that fermentation
is creating gas and that's when you get
that bloating distension acid reflux
a lot of women and men as well are
getting small intestine bacterial
overgrowth or sibo so all of that what
i've seen is one of the biggest things
that people can make an immediate
improvement on even if they aren't using
fasting is just simply cutting out
snacking not even changing their diet at
first but removing the snacks can help
massively to stimulate that mmc
and to be clear snacking is
anything like i mean i'm thinking like
you know oh so what if i have a coffee
with something in it what if i have
um like be clear like fast or snacking
is anything yeah anything other than
water so if you have um i mean there's
some debate and it can depend on each
person because technically speaking
stress can slow down the mmc as well so
you know some people get a stress
response in response to caffeine so even
though you know black coffee doesn't
contain technically any food or calories
that should disrupt mnc if you get a
stress response from it it can slow it
down
um so that's where if you really want to
maximize gut health having just water in
between your meals will make it so that
the mmc can stay stimulated
wow i i have tried some of that and i i
mean like more intermittent fasting and
more like less snacking i i wore a um
blood glucose monitor continuous blood
glucose monitor for a couple months
that is an education have you ever done
that
i have one i still haven't done it but
yeah i need to try it out i have a
glucose meter and a ketone meter but a
continuous glucose monitor one
yeah and and it's amazing how certain
foods will you know spike your insulin
and then just anything i mean any food
whatsoever you think like even you think
like oh i just had some protein like
protein does it too you know maybe not
as not as bad as a sweet potato but
right you know it it still does it so i
feel like that's kind of my first the
first phase of education i got which is
like digital proof right you're looking
at your
shoe
um
and um so so getting into the meat of
fasting and i have so many questions
because being a girl i just feel like
things must be different i mean like
what was your journey through the
testing of it all because i'm you seem
like the kind of person that has tried
it all on yourself yeah i did i started
off with the 16 hour which i don't
really recommend doing i recommend now
starting off with like a 12 hour just
because that's a really great way to
ease into the process so that you aren't
shocking your system and you're able to
more strategically plan out your meals
you can actually get enough of your
nutrient needs during the fast or during
the eating window rather um that's a big
problem with women that i've seen is
that they don't get enough during their
eating window and that's what makes it
unsustainable for them to continue on
with intermittent fasting and why they
get so hungry uh but we can get into
that in a bit but yeah i did the 16 hour
fast first and then i was like oh my
gosh i feel amazing if i feel great with
16 hours probably like i'll feel even
better with 20 hours or like a 24 hour
fast so i tried all those
and i made the mistakes that i now warn
people against where i didn't get enough
food for my body system because it's
really hard especially with protein to
get all those needs in during such a
short window and especially if you're
fasting for a full day you can't really
make up your protein needs from that day
with alternate day fasting for example
so whenever you see like studies that
are um talking about intermittent
fasting not being great for women
they're always talking about alternate
day fasting or extended fasting they're
never talking about time restricted
feeding and if they are it's when you're
not getting enough food for your body
where you're constantly in a calorie
restricted state which just in general
calorie restriction is horrible for
women it's already been found to cause a
lot of fertility issues with women long
term hormones it's hard on your hormones
right and so just to be clear though
alternate day fasting does that mean 12
16 12 16 or does that mean
24 and then you eat all day the next day
yeah it literally means one day fast one
day you don't so 24 hours yeah you fast
for 24 hours and then the next day you
don't fast you can eat like what's
called a quote-unquote normal day where
you wake up and eat right away i have a
lot of problems with the alternate day
fasting i know there's been some people
have seen success with it but not only
do you not get enough of your needs but
it's so not sustainable for life like
how do you plan out your life to be like
okay on this day i'm not going to fast
on that day and but it's it's john's
birthday on that day and i know we're
going to be going out to eat so am i
just going to like have sparkling water
like it doesn't make sense logistically
long term and i think that especially in
the intermittent fasting space it's so
filled with these like highly
overachieving people where they have the
ability and the discipline to like
schedule out their life to an alternate
day fast vertical nine out of 10 people
probably more than that can't do that or
don't want to do that and if we're only
preaching those methods then we're not
going to actually help everyone else
where you they could get so many results
with time-restricted feeding yeah so you
found that 16 was the best what did you
find with 18 and maybe you tried 18 or
maybe you just went to 20. and then did
you ever do omad as well one meal a day
i did try out omad so that's like a 22
hour fast essentially
um i also i again i have clients who
that works for them um i found most
people it doesn't because like let's
just say your protein needs like mine
are about 80 or 90 grams per day have
you ever tried to sit down and eat that
much protein at one meal it's not
clearly nearly impossible especially
from a complete protein source
i mean you're it's really hard to
actually get everything that your body
needs with a one meal day it can be done
some people do it well but i found for
myself at most i can do two meal a day
which you know will be about a six hour
eating window um so like an 18 hour fast
but i also find success with the 12 or
even 14 hour there were some recent
studies that showed um even if you could
just do 12-hour fasting per day you get
a lot of the same benefits as a 16 or an
18-hour fast really so what's happening
what's the science to why
we should be doing it i mean obviously
there's some gut help and we heard a
little bit about you know bloating and
that kind of stuff and letting the the
um the what's the mm what's the word
again yeah we can we could just leave it
to mmc it's migrating
but mmc is the easy term
there i mean it all comes down to if we
can understand the basic idea of what
our bodies need to do every day we need
to build up and we need to break down we
can't always be building we can't always
be breaking down so even if you look at
like with strength training with
workouts something that all of us are a
little bit more familiar with we know
that we need to work out which is
breaking down but then we also need rest
and that rest is where the muscle builds
back up right so it's the same thing
with literally everything else in our
body we need to have those ups and downs
we need for our gut we need to be
breaking down food so we can get the
nutrients we need but our gut is also a
machine so it needs rest in order to
have the you know the cleaning crew come
in to clean up what was left behind um
so that it can do its job efficiently
the next day same thing with our cells
like what you're talking about autophagy
or or mitochondria there's a lot of
different
like more specific biology terms there
um but basically your cells need to you
know they're always recreating itself um
each cell has a different lifespan but
we need to actually be able to break
down cells in order to create new cells
that are healthy again and that's with
fasting what you're doing we're always
in this state of perpetual building up
if you're eating all day long you're
always building you're always
trying to break down food so that you
can have that anabolic or build up state
but you never actually get into that
cleanup crew time and with yourselves
with your gut that's what you're really
focused on in terms of fasting each day
you